Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Tattletail.
Now if you notice by the eggs collected,
someone said it was very, very important to the story to get all the gift eggs,
so I went back and I played through up until this point again to try to make sure I get all of the eggs possible.
Now, I wanted to talk about why this game is scary
and it is--to me at least. I'm not going to say this game is scary to everybody, for - for me this game is terrifying.
And I find that it's mostly because
it's set up a lot of stuff.
Given that I play through it just again,
I realized that it set up a lot of things that didn't immediately happen.
It - it alluded to the possibility that there were going to be scares
and that there was unsettlingly creepy things going on in this game,
but it didn't get to it right away.
It wasn't until the third night that anything really scary actually happened.
Not even really scary, scary things happened, but it wasn't until...
the third night that something threatening actually happened.
So I'm on the lookout for even more eggs by the way.
Seventeen? Seventeen?! Did I miss some?
There's no way I could've missed some!
I was so close!
I was so careful.
I might've missed one; I have no idea. *Creepy Tattletail talking in the distance*
I've been tryin' my best.
*Tattletail talking*
Hi...
TTs: Me Tattletail. Me lo-ove you.
Okay, cool.
*Footsteps* (Awkward silence)
I'm sorry, did I interrupt something?
Carry on your conversation or whatever the fuck you were talking about
I'm sure it was super important.
"Grab Tattletail."
Grab which one?
Why are there two of you?!
I can't even pickup the other one.
(Winding noise) Hello!
TT: Me lo-ove playtime with you!
JESUS CHRIST!
TT: Let's play a game!
Shut up!
Holy shit! Don't yell at me! My god.
TT: No peeking!
Oh, I wouldn't dream of it.
Ooh.
*Light flickering noise, electricity buzzing, suspenseful music*
Survive for 30 seconds!?!
Ohhh.
OHH NOO!
Ohhh no!
Okay. Alright. I'mma stop being such a big baby.
(Static, electric noise.)
I, OH FUCKING GOD DAMMIT!
Fuck!
AHH!
Eh, eh, aaaaAH!
WHYYY?!
NUUUUGHHHH!
(Tattletail laughter)
Oh, okay.
Alright then, we did it, whoooh!
TT: Hide and seek!
Whoo!
Oh boy.
Oh!
Oh.
I - I don't know why I thought he'd be back here. Heh.
I'm an idiot.
Okay.
At least I got an egg, that I might not have gotten.
Oh, there we go, egg number thirteen, so I'm still on track.
I'm definitely on track, because I got up to twelve before.
Which meant that this one was the correct one, for this one.
So there's gotta be more eggs here.
And I want to find them.
I definitely want to find them all.
I don't know what the ending is,
but someone said it was incredibly important that I find all the eggs.
Then again, it might just be a red-herring.
Oh, I see you.
Okay, I see you!
TT: Me hiding.
Oh you're hiding so good!
Let me tell you how good you're hiding!
TT: Give me a treat!
Oh shut up!
Do I have to do that this all time? (Tattletail repeating)
SHUT UP! (Tattletail repeating)
OH SHUT UP!
TT: Give me a trea- Hehehehehe
Okay alright, good, you got your treat.
Man I'm gonna have to take care of his needs while running away from Mama.
TT:Hide and seek!
Okay!
TT: You found me!
I sure did!
You wanna- oh yeah we gotta play again don't we? Okay.
TT: No peeking!
I wouldn't dream of it, little buddy!
Hiiii...!
Oh I hate this.
(flashlight buzzing)
Oh, I... He-ey! ...
Heeeey!
Okay, maybe if I go down in the basement I'll be safe...
YEAH, THAT SOUNDS RIGHT!
(Footsteps)
FFFFUCK!
God dammit, I don't know why it's so creepy to me.
God, I just explained why!
*music intensifies*
Oh fuck, oh fuck.
HEEEEEEY!
*music intensifies*
HEEY, fucking stooooop..!
ARGHHH!!
NYGYAH!!
Oh no, which way are you going?
(Tattletail's alarm beeps)
TT: Uh ohhhh!
OH NO!
SHUT UP!
TT: Uh ohhhhhh!
Oh no that's not good that's not good that's not good...
That's not good that's not good!
(Tattletail repeats, voice low and distorted)
TT: Me hiding!
Oh God dammit!
Okay.
TT: Give me a treat!
Jesus Christ.
Okay alright I'll give you a treat, God dammit!
I'm just double checking for eggs!
Fuck, man.
(Tattletail repeating) Oh shut up!
Oh boy.
(Tattletail repeating) Oh boy.
Okay, let's see what we got here.
Christmas Light, found egg fifteen, okay.
So I'm getting better, I just need to get this goddamn treat.
(Tattletail repeats) Oh shut up !
(Tattletail repeats) I don't wanna, but here you go!
I don't know why! Why do you eat human food?
Doesn't make any sense!
I don't knooow..!
Oh hi.
There you are.
Hello...?
TT: You found me!
Please tell me..
Yeah, found you alright.
(mumbling) Are we going to play again...?
(sobs) Oh no!
I don't wanna!
We're gonna die..
(Distant Tattletail mumbling) TT: Hi, Mama... In the bedroom...
TT: Okaaaay, bye-bye...
Ok.
In what bedroom?
In my mama's bedroom..? Your mama's bedroom?
AHH F- FUCK!
God!
N-Nooo peeking!
(Lights blowing out)
(Distant Tattletail mumbling) Hi mama...In the bedroom.
TT: Okaay... Bye-bye
Ok..
So the moral of the story is, DON'T FUCKING DO THAT!!
God, what did i do wrong?
I mean i knocked on mama's door!
So MY mama...
And YOUR MAMA!
Are the exactly the same mama..
EeeeEEE!
EEEEAAAHH!
Don't do that no no no NO!
AHHHHAAY!!
Fuck off..!
With yeee!
Ok, NA NOT THAT ONE!
Oh I need to feed you!
OH KAY!
Okay Alright!, Goody GOODY,
ARGH!
AHHEY FUCK!
(Ominous music increases)
YEEEHAY!
I JUST NEED TO GROOM MY FURBY!
OH BOY, OH BOY!
It's too early to be losing my voice!
Aggh... Agghh
Gahhh!
FUCK!
Oh, fuck.
Okay..
Alright, it's fine, it's fine, IT'S FINE!
Oohboy, okay, all right.
Oww! My neck is so unbelievably tense right now.
Okay, so I just gotta get through this.
A minute and a half is not that long.
I've got nothing to worry about...
Everything is a hundred percent (100%) fine.
(Ominous music)
Oh fuuck...
(ominous music gets louder)
God that food meter just goes down so quick.
Fuckin stop.
Alright, we're fine.
I just need to stop being such a little baby.
(Footsteps, static)
Eeeaaaahhh!
Thats not good!
Oh ffffuuuck me!
NO THANK YOU!
(Tattletail laughs, ominous music stops)
Oh Fucking FINALLY!
Jesus
TT: Give me a treat!
Shut up!
(Tattletail repeats) I'll get to you in a god damm second
(Tattletail repeats)
Oh, shut up!
I get it!
I GET IT!! (Tattletail repeats)
(distant Tattletail laughter)
Fuck man... Jesus Christ...
Ugh man..
I can't belive I'm already losing my voice
Jesus. What did I do, what did I do to deserve this?
I don't know- Oh, hi..
(Tattletail laughs)
Hi.
Oh boy
oooh kaaay..
Swoosh
Heheh, a used bandage, oh boy
I've got seventeen of twenty-two
Only 5 left to go!
Great..
Taaaagg...
TT: You found me!
Yeah, I gotcha alright.
"Grab the VHS," oh..
I'm sure that's...
I'm sure that's good.
Is it a "Ring" style VHS?
And also why is there's so much ketchup down here?
That doesn't make any sense at all...
Do you things..feed off of ketchup?  Sheesh.
Alright any other egg? Any other... I can't even wrap
them back up
in a -
in his box.
Jesus.
So, I need to
play this VHS in my bedroom TV.
That sounds pretty good.
I'm really happy about that.
I don't see any other eggs, I think i got 'em all
These ones were a bit scattered but
they were where he was every time
So i think thats self-explanatory
(Mark whispers) What the fuck is that?
CAMERAS!?
Your gunna turn FNAF on me!?!?!?
Oh, no.
Oh, what is that? Why's it so dark!?
"Tattletail comm public, 10/22/98." Why..?
Why does, why does a VHS have controls like this?
That doesn't make any se- eeh
That doesn't make any sense
Oh shit. Ohh god.
Ooh noo..
Oh... Oh...
Hi Mama...
Oh, hi Mama
Oh, dont look at me Mama... oh god.
Oohh noo..
Ooo..
Is that a clickable?
No?
Okay
Alright. Okaaay...
Alright
(sounds of disgust)
Oh fuck...What is that??
Storage?
(Distorted music and singing)
Hey...!
(song continues)
Noooo!
(song continues, Tattletail makes eating noises)
What the fuck?
Wait. That's a body!
That's a body!
What the fuck?!
(Distrupting Mama voice) "Mama's comin'!"
TT: Play time for me!
Oh, fuck...
Oh my God!
(song fades, ends)
Ooh okay, alright...
That's another body!
That's a body!
That's a fucking body!
You can't fool me! That's a body!
That's literally a dead body.
Was he just taking a nap!?
Which is entirely possible, I suppose.
Yeeesh
EEesH
(creeped-out noises)
Okaaaay
Alright then.
TT: Wake up, wake up, wake up!
(Tattletail repeats)
Okay
I'm ready. Alright. What do ya got?
(Tattletail repeats) Okay, whatever.
Hi.
TT: You're up! We're having a party for mama.
TT: Come help us
I dont think I wanna do that
Y-You're awfully conversational. You know, you're
not even conversational in the way you
were before you're just havin' a normal conversation.
You're talking to me like a human would,
or a possessed demon doll would.
TT: Tattletail, that's me!
Why's the front door open..?
(distant Tattletail laughter)
Why's the front door open!?
Hi! Hello! Found you!
Oh my god, my voice is completely gone. (distant Tattletail laughter)
Oh no!
Found egg number nineteen,
collected 18 of 22, so... I don't think I
missed one in the last one, did I?
I hope I didn't.
Yeesh
Oddly enough, when i was playing through this again-
(interrupting) TT: Me Tattletail, me lo-ove you!
I was able to go through this...
I was able
to unlock this before. Like, there was a
way... if you went out... for that egg that
was on the front porch, you could go out
here and you could unlock it, and I
thought that was going to have an effect
later on... but it may have been training
me for the future. I don't know-
(interrupting) TT: Play time for me, game oooon!
Ooh hello!
(distant Tattletail laughter)
Swoosh~. Sea shell soap!
There we go! Number eighteen.
So I am on track. So, all of the other eggs are
on this level. This level alone. So I just
gotta find all of the eggs...
and everything's going to be okay.
And hey, look! I got a present!
Should I open it? Probably not!
TT: Me love play time with you!
Ookay
Hi
All right then
Well, I'm still a shitty brat.
A shitty meme-y brat that opens his presents too soon.
Yeesh
TT: Play time for me! Game ooon!
Hoookay, alright! Keep telling yourself that, alright!
God, I can't go in the back yard...
Alright
(winding noise)
(Tattletail laughs)
If I knock on Mom's door, is it gonna end in death?
(knocking) Okay...
TT: Tattletail, that's mee!
Mom's j-.... (ominous sounds)
Ooooh
That's the ONLY way to the basement!
There's no other way.
Oh no...
Oh noooo...
Oh I gotta go in the side basement...
Oh by the way, there are pictures of this
family, so this kid has a sibling, and
there are the parents pregnant with the
kid... and then there's pictures of cats.
TT: Me lo-ove playtime with you!
Alright, that's good...
Alright, let's go down staaairs...
Lets see what happens...
Ok
(distant Tattletail laughter)
I think I got all the eggs up there
(laughter gets louder)
Oh this is not gunna be good is it..?
Oooh..
Ooh hi!
Hi.. How's it goin'?
Ooh good, ooh great...
Is there any eggs for me?
TT: Me Tattletail, me lo-ove you!
Oh great! Alright!
(Tattletail laughs)
Just gonna use this
TT: More! More!
I thought I was gonna do that!
"Find a friend by the Christmas tree,"
Oooookay!
I-.....
Oh, thats not good.
(ominous music, footsteps)
Oh that's NOT good!!
Oh that's not good!
Oh.. that's not good...
Oh no...
O-ho-ooh why's Mama so upset??
(sniff) Why's Mama so m-mad?
Oh fuck..
Hey...
Hey!
(terrified groaning)
HI
(screeches)
(squeals)
(various noises of terror)
Oh fuck, okay, I'm outta here.
Fuck that shit
Fuck that shit right up, okay...
Fucking, hi!!!
Whoa, what the fuck?
How long have you been there?!
Uuuragh
Okay, alright!
Everything okay?
Everything fine?
Everything good, everything good?
ok
So I gotta get this guy...
so I gotta bring another friend into the fold, I think
that's what I'm supposed to learn here.
TT: Tattletail, that's meee!
TT: Mama's watching.~
Why is Mama watching!?
Mama shouldn't be watching!
FUCKING
(girly screams)
Oh god no!
Okay, alright, everything's- *jumpscare*
AAH FFFFUCK
Goddammit
Fuck you
Fuck you, you piece of shit
Ooooh, God dammit!
Fuuuuuck
TT: Wake up, Wake up, wake up! *mark's new alarm clock*
Oh, goddammit
Fuck you, dude
TT: You're in biiig trouble.
Oh NO I'M NOT!
Oooh boy, oooh boy! *jumpscare in 3*
Where's the door, where's the damn door?! (right in front of you lol)
Oooh fuuuck!! Come on!
Fuck
I'm in big trouble :(
It's okay, it's okay. (no it's not)
Ah! Fucking-
Oh fucking fuck!
COME OOOOON
What the fuck?!
This fucking bullshit!
Goddammit
TT: Mama hates yooou!
Mama doesn't hate me! (yes she does :P)
You don't know that about Mama!
Ooh, maybe you do know that about Mama...
Ooh, maybe you know that about Mama...
You might know that about Mama,
so just shut up
and be good
and then maybe Mama ain't gonna hate me no more!
Oh boy. That ain't good.
Yeeeee
Eeeeeeh!
hahoo!
TT: More! More!
Okay!
Alright!
Fuuuuck!
FUUCK!!
I dont know where I am, I dont know wh-
Oh fuck, why am I over here?
Oh, god damnit!
Ooooh, this is bullshit, ain't it?!
That aint good
this aint good, this aint good!
Oh fuck dude
Don't kill me please!
I-I like life!
I'm just a kid!
Why you gotta kill mee!
Maybe you're not?
Ooooh!
Maybe you're not!!
but I still can't help but think that this is probably gonna kill me
If I don't get this on the first go.
(lights flickering)
Fucking! Noo!
NOOOOoooo!
NOOOOOOOO!
Oh god no, oh no, oh no
Oh no, oh no, oh no...
Oooh nooo...
Ooh nooo..!
Oh no
OOooh no
Okay
So far so okay
So far so good!
Everything's okay
Everything's okay!
Everything's okay.
Its' a bad idea to be in here,
I'm gonna get cornered, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die,
I'm gonna dieeee!
TT: Tattletail that's meee!
(Deep Tattletail voice): Mama's coming!
NOOO
Oh fuck! Egg, egg, egg, eee-
OH FUUUUCK OH COME OON!!!
Fucking fuck
Don't put me in the beginning!
Oh fucking, what the fuck?
There's another egg here in the bush
Just get the egg...
Shoosh~
SHOoosh! It's a rabbits foot!
'Kay, there's only two eggs left
So I just gotta go for it.
TT: Play time for me! Game oooon!
Get outta here, get outta here , get outta here...
TT: Mama's coming!~
NO SHE'S NOT!
TT: Give me a treat!
NNNO!
Okay!
Okay, alright,
Everything's fine!
Woah wooooah,
(terrified noise)
Okay, I'll go the long way around!
FUUCK! No, I won't!
Woah fucking fuck!
(Deep Tattletail voice): Mamas coming!
No you're not!!!
OOh fuck dude!
Yeeesh!
Yeesh!
OH FUCKING
God Dammit!
FFFUCK
Fuck maaan!
(sighs)
Ok, everybody relax.
It's totally fine.
Now, for some reason
I screamed my entire voice out.
I don't know why,
I don't know how.
Maybe because this game terrifies me but
I'm going to give myself a little bit of
a breather before I finish this game!
I've almost got all the eggs
I just have to be very attentive of where they are
and also, I have to be very attentive of where
Mama is.
because Mama... is a problem
and Mama HATES me.
So
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know how I'm doing
down in the comments below, and if
you play this game or
if you haven't
played this game yet, try it for yourself.
So thanks again and as always, I will see -you-
in the next video! Bye bye!~